reversal man
look for these titles in bookstores this
coming week and watch for the authors in
the near future on book tv
coming up next on book tv russian
american journalist masha gessen
discusses her writings on russian
society and politics as well as her
recent book on the boston marathon
bombing
masha gessen is a russian-american
journalist
and author whose most recent book is the
brothers the road to an american tragedy
which tells the story of the tsarnaev
brothers
just last month
dzhokhar tsarnaev was convicted of all
30 charges against him in the boston
marathon
bombing trial
she's also the author of the man without
a face the unlikely rise of vladimir
putin
and words will break cement the passion
of [ __ ] riot
masha gessen has written extensively on
lgbt rights and helped found the pink
triangle campaign in opposition to
russian legislation banning gay
propaganda
she has been described as russia's
leading lgbt rights activist
and has said herself that for many years
she was probably the only publicly out
gay person in the whole of russia
here tonight in conversation with masha
gessen is peter finn
washington post national security
correspondent
please join me in welcoming masha gessen
and peter finn to the jccsf
thank you
good evening it's um wonderful to be in
san francisco and
i'm especially happy to be here with
masha um a gifted and fearless
journalist whose work i've admired for a
long time thank you peter and we've
recently had the opportunity to work
together when she blogged for the
washington post
um
let's jump right in
um you know russia has experienced a lot
of
trauma and turmoil since the fall of the
soviet union and
you've witnessed most of it
um
but as you look at russia now
and the war in ukraine the assassination
of boris nemtsov
the crackdown on the lgbt community
an opposition that looks like it's been
completely marginalized
a docile media
how pessimistic are you about the
current situation and the opportunity if
any for change
very
that maybe all i have to say on the
topic if you've gone through the whole
list but
i
i think things are even worse than what
you described
it's not you know just the war in
ukraine it's
russia perceives itself as a country at
war with the west
and so it's a war that's going to
escalate
um i also think that the next stage of
that war is going to be a crackdown on
what
putin has increasingly been referring to
as the fifth column the enemy within
the you know the or what he's also
called the national traders
uh
so there's going to be a major political
crackdown that will make the last three
years of political crackdown
seem like a dress rehearsal
so i think we'll see a lot of arrests
and uh
and possibly a lot more physical attacks
like the assassination stuff and you
wrote in the new york times that the
scariest thing about the murder of
borrison himself was that he himself did
not scare anyone
um
and if he was politically harmless why
was he killed
i think he was he was killed as a
message first of all uh i also i don't
think that
i mean a couple of things about his
murder uh he was killed in plain view of
the kremlin so he was he was killed on a
bridge that crosses the moscow river
directly across from the kremlin
and if you
so much as take out a zoom camera on
that bridge you will have the police on
you within a matter of seconds i was
once in a group of bicyclists who were
going under the bridge and the
presidential guard ran out to intercept
us because it was an unusual occurrence
to see a group of bicyclists go under
the bridge so we
we see on the surveillance tapes that
there was a body lying on the bridge for
at least 10 minutes and nobody came to
to look at what happened uh so what does
that say uh well one other thing that i
want to say before before i say what it
says is that but it is also like other
people
who are opposed to putin and i try not
to use the word opposition i can explain
why not in a minute but um
like other people who are who are
actively opposed to putin he was under
constant surveillance and he would
especially have been under constant
surveillance that day
because the following day there was
going to be a protest march that he had
organized
so this is a murder that very clearly
took place in plain view of the kremlin
of the presidential guard and the fsb
the russian secret police
so at the very least it was a crime that
was allowed to happen at most of the
crime that was actually carried out by
the kremlin
but
what it communicates is something that
is also related to an occurrence in
moscow a week earlier which was the
so-called anti-maidan march and this is
the latest of these uh kremlin organized
and sponsored so-called popular
movements or
fake popular movements
this one is explicitly intended to
prevent a ukrainian-like revolution in
russia as though russia had uh any
chance of seeing ukrainian-type
revolution
and a lot of the people who marched in
that uh 30 000 strong march in moscow
actually carried placards with a
portrait of nymsof
that identified him as an organizer of
the ukrainian revolution
so
uh the message of that march was that
the kremlin is forming and unleashing
a
force you know a paramilitary force a
band of thugs
for the
very explicit purpose of attacking
people who are opposed to putin
and their first target was named is that
organized by the kremlin or it was
organized by the kremlin yeah so you see
them as directly complicit in the
in the murder yes do you think they
directly organized it i don't think
that's necessary i mean there isn't a
sort of clear chain of command is
actually not necessary in an environment
like that where the most important
messages are
messages of what can be what kind of
violence can be carried out with
impunity what kind of violence will be
interpreted as being uh done in the name
of the regime and uh and to to help the
regime
and
i mean who are these people then do you
have any sense are they part of the
state apparatus are they part of the fsb
are they um people who support putin i
mean well there's certainly puts into
support people who support puss and i
think they're opportunistic thugs
basically
who
know they have free reign exactly and
they will join whatever
what whatever entity will allow them to
have free reign and engage in violence
with impunity
um if you know if you listen to people
in the kremlin and and some in state
media they
they argue that they're in an
information war with the west and
and that we're all swimming in a sea of
lies there are our lies their lies your
lies my lies and that there's no
difference between the new york times
and russia today
i mean do you do you see that that
is how that's what direct is directing
russian state media policy
i think that's actually i think it goes
deeper than that and it's that's a
really interesting question because i
actually think that that's one of the
few things they say that really truly
express their world view i think they uh
the people who
run russian media work for russian media
really believe
that we're all liars that the whole
world is constructed exactly this way
everything is bought and sold everyone
is bought and sold no one ever uh holds
sincere convictions
everything is said for a purpose beca or
you know
said in the name of the highest bidder
and they're so sincerely convinced
that that this this is not just the way
they conduct their lives but the way
that the entire world works
that they interpret any message coming
at them from the outside
as an expression of that same event but
do you see is is that top to bottom or
that is just the leadership is everyone
that cynical i think it's pervasive yeah
and i think i think it's it's really
what we've inherited from from the
totalitarian society
that's that's a part of the soviet
legacy where
you know for 70 years we lived in a
country that where every word was used
to mean its opposite and when they said
democracy they meant
lack of democracy when they said freedom
they meant prison i mean read in 1884
but if you're walk into a russian media
organization you'll see people many who
were born after the fall of the soviet
union
well the fall of the soviet union wasn't
accompanied by a dissembling of the of
that system of propaganda it wasn't you
know the uh russia actually made a
series of choices in the early 1990s
to avoid reckoning with its past i mean
russia never you know removed soviet
soviet monuments russia never banned
soviet movies from tv russia never
prosecuted the communist party that's a
really interesting
story that you know russia assembled the
prosecutor's office assembled a case
against the communist party to the tune
of 80 volumes and then placed it under
lock and key and decided to let sleeping
dogs lie so uh you know the generation
of people who grew up in the 90s had
this really schizophrenic experience of
reality where their parents on the one
hand were going out and trying to make a
living and trying to navigate
a world that had become suddenly very
difficult and very confusing
and at the same time they were watching
soviet movies on television when they
weren't watching latin american soap
operas and
uh and in the soviet movies everything
was so clear and everything was so
beautiful and everyone was so beautiful
sort of spiritually and physically
and
and all that seemed
necessary to to have happened is just to
return that to that imaginary period of
total clarity but you know the the
experience in eastern europe with
prosecution with lustration as it was
called has been mixed and some people
you know
feel that that kind of persecution could
divide the societies in in ways that
would not be helpful to democratic
development
well i think uh
i think we should explain what the
illustrations were right uh illustration
is a process that was set into motion in
countries like germany and and and the
czech republic where uh people who'd
held certain jobs say in the security
apparatus or in the communist party
apparatus were banned from holding state
jobs
uh and so that meant they were
identified and they were officially
disqualified um i don't know that that
kind of reckoning always works but i'm
pretty sure it's the only thing that
works
because um we had
a version of that reckoning in iraq
which certainly didn't work when the
bathursts were from at all levels were
tossed out of government and the army
was disbanded
um
it may not be a parallel experience but
um
i think it's
it's probably a different experience
when it's done it by country under
military occupation true
um in the sen when you talk about
eastern europe um and central europe
we see the kremlin now making
in some ways strange alliances with
far right parties and in
eastern europe what do you think is
motivating this
the kremlin is completely politically
opportunistic
i mean
they're
uh they have a mission and the mission
uh
and they have an idea right they so the
idea is that russia is
a country that is part of the
traditional value civilization which is
at war
with western civilization
western civilization has been trying to
force its decadent values down russia's
throats
russians throats
and the throats of other traditional
values countries
and russia is the only traditional
values country that has the courage of
its convictions
to go to war over traditional values
right so that's that's sort of the basic
idea underlying
russia's policies
uh so there you know there's nothing in
that idea that that has there's no
political kernel there and um and it
actually allows russia to make weird
political alliances
uh because it it sees itself as being in
confrontation with the west and so any
um any party in western europe that as
opposed to the european union is a good
ally so that can be the far right or the
far left so as we saw in greece yeah
they brought the far right and the far
left together and then russia was
instrumental in that in france it's the
far right in finland it's the far
right and germany they're reaching out
to both sides of the political spectrum
so well let's
how much of this is driven by putin
himself by the president i mean let's
get to a basic question about what
drives vladimir putin and what kind of
russia does he want
what drives vladimir putin is that he
wants to stay in power and he plans to
do it for life and he never plans to die
so that you know that that sort of
creates a a a a very
um
high
benchmark uh
because yeah you know he needs to stay
in power eternally um and he needs a
lofty enough mission
to ensure that he stays in power
eternally which is i think you know why
this uh this idea of russia as a
civilization
civilization state
and this this idea of a traditional
value civilization
they are suitable they're ambitious
enough to just to support this plan for
staying in power eternally
um now in terms of who's pulling the
levers in uh in the kremlin
on the one hand i think it's right to
acknowledge that it's a closed system
and we have only anecdotal
evidence of what goes on in there
the fact that it's a closed system
uh is terrible i mean it basically means
that it's the kind of system that can
only implode it cannot really be
affected by by outside forces
uh from what i've seen and what uh
what i've been able to sort of the
information i've been able to collect is
a lot of lovers are really concentrated
and puts in its own hands
but and
i mean you wrote a biography of putin i
mean how difficult is it
to report on him or to gather
information on him
and to talk to people in his
inner circle to talk to people in
um just beyond that point
it wasn't any more difficult than to
report the book on the tsarnaev brothers
in some ways it was easier
really i think people would be surprised
that
getting inside the kremlin is easier
than than getting inside the fbi yes
[Laughter]
the kremlin um
the kremlin is full of vain mediocre
people
who uh actually that doesn't really
market us particularly different from
the fbi but um
um but there were there were people who
wanted to talk to me just for the uh
for the glory of talking right to to a
journalist
uh and and who i think you know didn't
have a strong idea of of of discipline
or loyalty that would prevent them from
uh from talking to me
there's also a lot of the work that i
did when i was writing uh the book about
putin the man without a face
was just looking very closely at his
public statements uh because i think
that that's that's sort of part of what
uh journalists should do there's a lot
of information out there that sometimes
we don't take enough time to to examine
and interpret and i think that putin was
a very strange politician he was a
politician who hadn't had a public
record before becoming leader of this
huge country he had been a secret agent
his entire life
so
he was able to communicate what he
wanted the world to know about him
when he came to power and it was
actually a manageable amount of
information i mean i could like listen
to every recording ever made of his
speeches several times over and still
have time to to write the book
in a couple of years
but it was very interesting for example
to do to read closely
his uh official biography which was
based on a series of interviews that he
did with the team of three journalists
uh and he told the same stories over and
over again and these are the stories
that he wanted to have out there and
these were all stories about how he got
into fights
uh and they're all all the fights would
always play out uh in
in the same fashion so putin
loses his temper and hits somebody and
then seems to calm down for a while and
then loses his temper again and goes
after that person when they least expect
it
and you would get that story from putin
and from other people talking about
putin you know with his stamp of
approval
uh and so what he basically wanted to
communicate was that he was a vengeful
thug who had trouble controlling his
temper i mean he came right out and said
it and nobody particularly wanted to
listen
and but he was talking about when he was
a kid and and a young kgb officer he
even emphasized uh or had someone else
emphasize
that he was willing to risk his entire
career
to get into a fight uh on the subway in
st petersburg and
i mean how formative do you think the
kgb experience was for him i mean he he
spent a real you know a period of time
before the collapse of the soviet union
he was a lieutenant colonel he was in
the backwater in east germany i mean he
wasn't a prominent kgb
operative he wasn't prominent but he was
very committed and i also don't think
that he left the kgb when he says he did
which was in 1991 before he kind of said
he left and then he said he left again
exactly which suggests that maybe he
didn't leave
uh
and uh no in his story his story about
leaving the kgb is is infinitely change
changeable and changing and and not
credible at all uh but um he was born
into the kgb his father was an inca
officer uh and and then sort of an
active reserve and covered and cavite
was the precursor agency to the kgb
um he had ambitions of joining the kgb
from the time he was a kid
he first tried to volunteer when he was
a high school student
he finally got recruited into kgb when
he graduated from university and all he
ever wanted was to be this uh the secret
agent ruling the world from the shadows
he didn't particularly want to be
president of russia ruling
the country openly although he seems to
have gotten the taste of it after the
taste of it after a while and
when he he was in east germany when um
east germany when the wall came down and
there's this famous you know moscow is
silent they're there they're trying to
figure out what to do
and nothing is coming from moscow i mean
how formative do you think that
experience was for him i think it's huge
and again uh you know i'm not so much uh
playing sort of the armchair
psychologist as i'm just listening to
what he's told us uh
it's clearly a really important thing
that happened to him so what happened he
was he worked as a paper pusher in the
kgb office in dresden so
a
small city in germany
germany was being
rocked by anti-soviet protests
protesters gathered in front of the kgb
building
in dresden
putin was afraid that that people were
about to storm the building
he called the
soviet army headquarters in berlin and
asked for
for protection
and they said we can't send anybody
unless we get an order from moscow and
moscow is silent
and so he went back inside the the
building and started burning documents
that were collected in this building uh
and he burnt them
in in the stove until the stove cracked
from the heat
um you are one of i mean
among the people i know who've actually
met putin you had you were invited to
the kremlin
um
which struck me as highly unusual but
i'm wondering if you could tell us
highly unusual too
if you could tell us that
what happened why you were invited and
what happened so i wasn't invited
because i wrote a book about putin
but
but this happened
about six months after the book came out
i was editing a popular science magazine
and
i was asked to send
my publisher called me on a saturday
morning and asked me to send a reporter
to cover
putin hang gliding with the siberian
cranes
and
i took a very uh
really actually not a very brave
uh stand uh
i said look you know we're a popular
science magazine we don't have to do
this we can just i actually have a story
assigned
on the siberian
on the on the campaign to reap on the
campaign to repopulate the population of
siberian cranes and um
you know we could just do like without
putin because if i send a reporter then
the reporter will see something and then
i will be obligated to put in the
magazine and you're not going to want me
to put in the magazine
and we're going to have a problem let's
just not see anything
and
and the publisher said no why don't you
send a reporter
and then we don't have to publish
anything and i said well that i can't do
if the reporter goes then
and brings something back then i have to
publish it so he said well okay in that
case you're fired
uh and um
and then on monday i went into work and
signed the papers about my firing and i
tweeted and there are probably some
russian speakers in the audience i
tweeted
i'm not going to translate anyway um
it actually indicated that i was leaving
my job and it was putin's fault
and so he called me the next day um
he called you directly he called me on
the phone and he said it's vladimir
vladimirov
and uh
and i thought well this is like
a really inventive prank and i have to
come up
i have to come up with something really
witty to say because this is going to be
on youtube
but it was early in the morning i
couldn't come up with anything
and he kept talking and he said i want
to talk to you about my nature
conservation efforts do you mind and i
said no i don't mind but like how do i
know you are who you say you are
and he said well after we hang up the
deputy head of my administration is
going to call you and schedule a meeting
and then i will show up and then you'll
know that i am who i am
and and that sounded reasonable so uh
so i went to the kremlin and um
the amazing thing about it aside from
just the experience of uh
uh
of hearing from somebody who in a way i
felt like i had made up i mean i spent
all this time
uh trying to get in the man's head but
i'd never seen him in person so so he
was like a character in my book right
and he was going to come alive
and um
i it wasn't the first time that i wrote
a book about someone i couldn't
interview i had the book before that was
about the russian mathematician grigori
perelman
who solved the point correct conjecture
and then
refused the million dollar prize
for the person who solved it
and so i um
after putin and i got off the phone i uh
i google hanged out my my editor and
senior putin just called and
and she said how are you meaning like do
you feel safe
and i was like well i'm excited but it
would be more exciting if berman had
called
but
but
but i really wanted to see what this
person was like and uh he was pretty
much the person in the book he was there
there were no surprises there part of me
was hoping that he would like come alive
and wouldn't be as two-dimensional as
the person that i had described but he
wasn't
uh but the highlights were basically two
one was that when i walked in he said i
like kitties and puppies and little
animals
and
and that was meant to communicate that
he really
is serious about the siberian cranes
and
and the other thing was that he didn't
know who i was i mean he knew i was
editor of this magazine that he liked
and the idea of calling me in was to put
me back in my job because he liked the
magazine a lot and if he likes something
that he thinks he owns it which is sort
of part of what's gone wrong with russia
and uh
um
but he had not been briefed on me he
didn't realize i was an american citizen
he didn't realize that i had been an
opposition journalist for a long time or
that you'd written a biography or that
i'd written a biography just that's
unbelievable
i mean what kind of staff does he have
that
uh well the problem is that for him to
know that a book that critical of him
had come out in 20 languages someone
would have had to tell him
and nobody wanted to tell him that
especially after he called me
you said
you know he struck you as
two-dimensional and i think a lot of
people would find that you know
hard to fathom because here is a man who
he did come to power as president he's
held on to power for 15 years he's shown
quite an ability to wield it and to
crush his enemies um how does a
two-dimensional figure manage all of
that
it's a really interesting argument
because i keep getting into this
conversation with a lot of people and
it's like
uh the stephen codkin who's who is a
great historian of russia and and the
author of a new biography of selling he
uh he mentioned this in a recent article
that i
make a case for putin being a mediocrity
and an accidental president
and then he raised this one line but
nobody who no accidental person can stay
in power this long
and i don't know where that assertion
comes from because uh actually well
he has right and uh
and there is no definitive proof that he
is three-dimensional or intelligent or
skilled
uh and there's there's a lot of
indications that he's
not not very well educated
uh
not very well informed man with very
strong instincts for sort of playing
people off against one another
and for holding on to power but he's
also
uh in office in a country where sort of
the magic of office is huge
uh and where it was very it proved very
easy for him to dismantle the democratic
mechanisms that existed when he came in
and to set into motion
uh all the totalitarian mechanisms that
had been dormant for a couple of decades
you mentioned the storks and
that's just one of many stunts that
we've seen you know he's gone
diving in the sea for antiquities he's
been with the tigers and
um and the polar bear and he's been in a
submersible and he's flown a fighter jet
and and driven a submarine yeah so
what's what's this about is this
burnishing a public image for
the russian public
i mean the bear chest the horseback all
of it there's sort of distinct periods
like there was his early uh probably his
first eight years were all about driving
so it was like flying a plane
and piloting um yeah piloting the
submersible and then piloting a um
an aircraft carrier and a submarine
and so i think these were sort of
he was king of the world and
transportation
and uh
and then there was like the king of the
jungle period which was uh
which was the
the siberian cranes and the tigers and
the uh and the polar bear and these are
always uh these are always the largest
animals of their kind
so they're very carefully chosen
uh and then there was the bear chested
uh sort of sex symbol uh
the
period of virility
um
and now there's the war in ukraine
um
he remains i mean i if we can talk a
little bit about his popularity or his
apparent popularity among the russian
public um and i think lavada
recently had it which is an independent
polling agency in russia had his
approval ratings over 80 percent
88. yeah yeah obviously the state media
all of that plays a role but at the same
time there seems to be some connection
there
that his popularity isn't entirely
manufactured
i think
it's really difficult to talk about
because all the word the language that
we have to talk about opinion polls and
popularity figures
uh are all
it's all based on our experience of
studying opinion in democratic societies
and um
the thing is that what what putin has
done over the last few years really is
setting in motion the mechanisms of a
totalitarian society and i think he's
done something that has never been done
before which is retrofit a totalitarian
system
and
one of the things that have kicked in
is what happens to
popular opinion in a totalitarian
society which is that
it's a matter of survival to know
what to think and to say
and it's very very difficult to draw a
distinction between what people say
sincerely and what people say because
they uh
they know they're supposed to say it
because actually they know they're
supposed to be sincere about it in fact
it's a matter of survival to be sincere
about it right and there's a very very
small minority uh
roughly that you know 12 to 15 percent
uh that stays stably
anti-anti-putin and
anti-kremlin policy in opinion polls
that seems to have some resistance to
that right
one of the things that we've seen emerge
um
in his latest term is
this kind of state-sponsored homophobia
and i'm wondering if you could tell us
firstly what this
anti-gay propaganda law is and does and
why you think it emerged at this
juncture
i think it emerged almost by accident uh
what what happened three years ago was
that putin came back for his third term
as president
um
and
he was faced with and something
unprecedented
which is popular protests and there were
protests going on all over russia
and he found them really genuinely
frightening
the protesters didn't have any
mechanisms for overthrowing putin or for
even preventing his claiming any
percentage in the election which he
ended up claiming 63
in the presidential election but um
but he's he is actually personally and
historically very frightened of
protesters and i think that goes back to
to that scene in dresden which which is
so important to him
and and he felt like
the kremlin had lost control of the
country this was something that he
communicated
to his close subordinates that they had
let this happen
so they needed to engineer crackdown and
they also needed to mobilize the country
against the protesters and so he started
out by throwing out just random insults
at the protesters the first thing he
said about them was that
they were personally inspired by hillary
clinton and uh and that they the white
ribbon that that became the symbol of
the protesters
that a lot of people were on their
lapels he said that from the from a
distance
it looked like a spent prophylactic and
that that people for some reason decided
to to
pin these empty condoms to their lapels
uh which is
you know some sort of sort of allusion
to a lack of virility on the part of the
protesters i guess um and then you know
it was a short step to to starting to
gay bait the protesters uh
and that really got traction uh and the
thing this is this is what um tim snyder
calls this a calculated cacophony
uh they throw out a lot of messages and
then they are actually obsessed with
feedback they're obsessed with uh with
with polling numbers
so they keep a very close track of uh
what works and the gay baiting really
worked
and i think it worked for for for very
clear reasons it was great shorthand for
saying that there are other they're
western
they're not uh
they're they're not russian they're
enemies of russia
they are also part of what has been
strange about russia and uncomfortable
about russia since the soviet union
collapsed because we didn't have any
openly gay people until after the soviet
union collapsed so you could say all of
that in just by gay baiting the
protesters
um and that's then it sort of started
ballooning into this whole idea of
traditional values
um and you know obviously i'm i'm
simplifying it and i'll write a whole
book about that and it'll be a little
bit more complicated uh but
russia has always the russian government
has traditionally worked hand-in-hand
with the russian orthodox church and
especially in times of crisis
and this was true even during the soviet
period that the kremlin would reach for
the church like during world war ii
exactly uh to to sort of to to to
fortify its position
so this was happening as uh uh as putin
was running his presidential campaign
which is why [ __ ] riot went to jail uh
and uh [ __ ] riot were protesting the
fact that the patriarch of the russian
orthodox church was campaigning for
putin
so this unholy alliance of the kremlin
and the russian orthodox church came up
with this uh idea of tradition of the
traditional values civilization and the
centerpiece of that idea was the
anti-gay campaign and how is the lgbt
community responding are people leaving
are they
hiding are they
able to fight back in any way
i don't think it's possible to fight
back and not just because the lgbt
community is still quite small and weak
in russia but
it's it's impossible to fight back
against the
monolith
of the russian state with all the media
at its disposal
all the mechanisms of repression at its
disposal i mean there's nothing you can
uh you can put up against that
so a lot of people have left uh and a
lot of people have come to this country
uh the
i know of hundreds of people who've come
just in new york city lgbt refugees in
new york city there are a lot of people
in san francisco a lot of people in dc
some people are trying to to stay low
and and hope that this ends in the
foreseeable future and obviously this
affected you personally i mean you've
had death threats in the past
over the course of your career you've
taken great risks
in reporting in chechnya among other
places and yet at this moment you
finally decided you had to leave russia
well reporting in chechnya in some ways
i mean war reporting which i think
you've done too is
you
you go there and then you come back and
you're safe and it's like the
um
the fact that you can remove yourself
from danger is actually is actually part
of what makes war reporting so appealing
and addictive
uh when you're threatened in your own
home that's a little different
and um basically i was i was
it was communicated to me that the state
would go after my oldest son who's
adopted and that they would try to annul
the adoption
so that was uh
even sort of before i got into the
technicalities and the and the issue of
how this was legally possible which it
is as it turns out
uh just
sort of the visceral understanding that
that they could actually go after my
kids was too much to take right
and you mentioned the orthodox church i
mean
russia has four official
religions right um
orthodoxy judaism islam buddhism
how are the other denominations
responding to this
close political relationship now between
the orthodox church and the kremlin
um that's a great question uh well
the the relationship actually the
cooperative relationship is working with
all the denominations so uh
and uh and you can see that even
for those of us paying attention to it
there was a recent photo op with putin
and representatives of the four official
religions
all you know carefully placed to
communicate the hierarchy of religions
uh you know the the the two rabbis are
standing farthest away from putin um and
and and then move to a little bit closer
and you know the patriarch closest uh
but um
the the the relationship between
uh the more liberal wings of of of of
each religion and and the more
conservative and the traditional
state control structures which never
went anywhere uh basically mimics in all
the other religions that mimics what's
happened in the russian orthodox church
where the
um
the more liberal wing has been all but
destroyed in the last few years
um before we move on to boston one final
question in this
area um
[Music]
you know the west and the united states
in particular over the last several
years has you know
struggled in how to
what kind of relationship to have with
russia and with president putin
you know we've had engagement and then
we've had
isolation we've had reset we've now have
sanctions and i mean
obviously you're not in government but
is it appropriate to isolate russia to
sanction russia or as others argue
stephen cohen for instance that it is in
the national security interest of the
united states regardless of the form of
government in russia
to have a working relationship with that
government
russia is an extremely unreliable
partner i mean
the latest example is the are the
negotiations with iran which russia
basically
you know participated
it appeared to be participating as a
partner in the negotiations and then the
day after the negotiations were
completed uh and and and the deal was
signed russia announced its unilateral
decision to to sell weapons to iran
so uh and this is uh it's
it's a classic sort of puts in gesture
it's the
uh you've been had again message
russia has no particular strategic
interest in selling those particular
weapons to iran
uh it does have a strong interest
in communicating that sort of message to
the united states so i don't see any
argument for dealing with a partner uh
that that will
uh
be unreliable well that will unreliably
be unreliable at every turn
and no uh in a certain with ukraine
we've seen that uh
no amount uh there's nothing the west
can do
that can influence what putin does
so that sort of frees the west up to do
the right thing which is uh which is not
to be in bed with a dictator and not to
aid him in any way and not to engage him
in any way and not to give him the honor
of being recognized
uh as as a partner in in any enterprise
um turning to the united states and in
particular to boston you've just
published a book obviously
on the bombing and um and i guess the
question everyone asks and this won't be
the first time you've heard it but is
you know why did they do it what did
they want to achieve
um
well
that's yeah
that that's the question that we always
ask about ask about terrorists and the
traditional answer uh which
that
has been given since 9 11
is you have to find sort of the
radicalization narrative right and the
radicalization narrative which we get
from both the fbi and a lot of the
media coverage
is there's a huge international
organization that recruits a young man
or or two young men
and takes them through identifiable
stages
where they're first pre-radicalized and
radicalized and finally they become
terrorists
this obviously didn't happen in this
case
it actually hasn't happened in other
other cases either but this case has
really exposed the fact
that it doesn't work that way
so it's forced the government into
rather the rather uncomfortable position
of using a new term which we heard over
and over again during the trial in
boston which is self-radicalization so
it's like tamerlan tsarnaev recruited
himself and took himself through the
stages of radicalizing himself
which sounds silly because because it's
it's useless right the whole uh
radicalization
theory is it's not exactly meaningless
but it's useless in the sense that
radical beliefs actually don't predict
terror's behavior most people who hold
radical beliefs including radical
beliefs that support violence
don't go and build bombs
a lot of some of the people who go and
build bombs and
even set them off don't have radical
beliefs
so and terrorism scholars have been
telling us this for years right it's
it's the fbi that that has been telling
us a different story
um
so i think that
and what terrorism scholars have been
telling us is that
people like the tsarnaev brothers
actually fit the profile that they see
perfectly what they usually see is
immigrants
young men with a secular education so
not steeped in in religion
contrary to to the popular image of this
um
usually
middle cla with a middle class
background but increasingly marginalized
and usually with a very small and close
social circle
that um within which they form sort of
all of their connections all of this is
true of the tsarnaev brothers it's also
true of millions of other people who
also don't go and build bombs right so i
mean we keep coming up again so is there
is there an x factor is there something
that pushes someone
over the line
i don't think there's an identifiable
factor what i do think is important to
understand is what sort of
what is so tempting and alluring on the
other side
which is that terrorism is a ticket to
belonging it's and it's a ticket to
belonging to something great
right you can go directly from being a
nobody and nobody feels more like a
nobody than an immigrant
to you know being somebody who declares
war on a great power and the miraculous
power of terrorism is that you know not
only do you feel like you belong to a
great entity and you declare war and a
great power but the power accepts your
declaration of war i mean the entire
rhetoric with which not just the united
states but the entire western world
reacts to terrorism is this rhetoric of
war they have attacked us
well actually no they didn't attack us
they set off bombs they they committed a
horrible crime they killed three people
and injured 264 and 16 people lost their
legs but they didn't attack the american
nation
they set off bombs at the boston
marathon they committed a horrible crime
and they should be treated as criminals
we should criminalize this we shouldn't
make it a matter of war or
conflict or whatever
the yes i think that you know the sort
of like the spectacle if you remember
from january
of
the leaders of the european nations
marching information
through the streets of paris
which seems sort of so inspiring at
first sight
is exactly i think the wrong reaction
because uh why should they have the
power to get you know angela merkel to
march in paris
so what should
angela merkel or or francois hollande or
anyone do i mean they can't sit in their
office and ignore it
i think they should prosecute them to
the fullest extent of the law
while treating them as common criminals
you know as as heinous murderers
and and the trial itself i mean you've
you've written that the
you found the quality of lawyering at
the trial
really excellent but at the same time
you found it somehow
not satisfactory in getting to what we
might call the truth although writing
about it for you was really fun thank
you but uh it's i mean
the american justice system is not
designed to get at the truth
uh and that's you know it's not uh it's
not a bad thing it's just it's the
adversarial process
isn't designed
to to conduct an investigation like
france has an inquisitory system where
the judge can actually order witnesses
in and can and can propose questions to
try to figure out what happened
the american process is designed to hear
two different narratives
to and and to see who makes it the most
convincing case and
the point of it is to apportion guilt
and assign punishment
the point of is not
to get a comprehensive picture of what
happened that's the fbi's job
and the fbi hasn't done this job but at
the same time i mean if you look at what
the defense did i mean we got a fairly
simple narrative from them which is he
did it
and
their um
their focus has been on
and not disputing his guilt but on
preventing him from being sentenced to
death
which is exactly their job and i think
they've they've done it spectacularly i
mean it's been uh
it's been amazing to watch it sucks it's
also been amazing to watch the
prosecution which was even more of a
surprise for me or actually that was a
surprise
just the way that they selected
witnesses the way they staged the case
the way they always timed it
to go from sort of mundane in the
morning and incredibly emotional
uh in the late afternoon to let the to
have the jury go home at the end of the
week
pondering the absolute worst of what
happened at the marathon
uh i mean it was it was just
it was like watching an incredible
theater production and
and it was devastating i mean i think it
was devastating for uh
not just for the people in the courtroom
but for the entire city of boston which
is why you've heard victims coming out
against the death penalty and just
asking to have this thing over with
because it is so emotionally powerful
um
but
you know
why do i find it unsatisfying because
there are questions that haven't been
answered that can't be answered in court
so one question is where were the bombs
made
and the fbi testified in court that they
don't know where the bombs were made
they know that they weren't made in
timerlan's apartment and they weren't
made in jahar's dorm room so they were
made somewhere else they were made
somewhere else then
who else was involved was this person
unwittingly involved whoever owns or you
know uh rents the space where they build
the bombs or was this a full accomplice
and we don't know unless the fbi tells
us and then the the biggest question is
what was the relationship between the
fbi and tamaran tsarnaev somebody whom
they interviewed at least three times in
2011 as a terrorism risk
uh you know how come they
he was then able to build a bomb and set
it off well i mean
napolitano who reviewed your book in the
new york times said you were a
conspiracy theorist for raising
uh questions about the role of the fbi
because from her point of view the fbi
does thousands of assessments of
people every year and the fact that they
didn't immediately recognize him
is indicative from her point of view of
nothing
uh
well i mean janet napolitano seems a
little conspiracy-minded about
conspiracy theories because all i did
was raise the question
but
but here's what happened the bombs went
off on monday afternoon on tuesday
morning fbi technical specialists had
isolated the likenesses of the brothers
from surveillance tapes
and then for three days basically until
after daryl and tsarnaev was killed
they couldn't identify the brothers
i'm
assuming that even though i mean i know
that the joint terrorism task force in
boston isn't that large the number of
people who go out to interview real live
terrorism suspects is finite
three days is definitely enough time to
show each one of those people
the pictures uh that they had isolated
from the videotapes
is it conceivable they didn't show them
the pictures absolutely but it's a sign
of incompetence
and incompetence may well
be the you know the biggest missing link
that the fbi is not disclosing
um
throughout the the proceeding in boston
um
the defendant has sat there i mean have
you learned anything about him through
this whole process
um he's sat there
looking like
like he's a little bit older than the
teenager he was during the marathon
bombing he's been mostly impassive you
can't really tell anything uh
um about his emotional reaction except
that he will not make eye contact with
any of the witnesses
uh it's been really
uh
kind of moving for me to watch his
relationship with the defense
because he's
he's under special administrative
measures or sams
which is a particular kind of hell
imposed on
terrorism suspects
it's it's like extreme solitary
basically he has no physical contact
with anybody
but prison guards and his lawyers when
they come to visit he cannot have visits
from anyone but immediate family and no
more than once a week and he has to
speak english to them because the fbi
has to be able to listen in he can only
write one letter a week
to the tune of three
single-sided sheets of paper and only to
an immediate family member and the fbi
has been able has to be able to read it
so
he has almost no human contact and it's
very clear that the defense the members
of the defense team
uh go to pains to have that kind of
human contact with him but it's only
going to get worse i mean
assuming that he gets a life sentence he
will spend it at a super max in colorado
where the conditions will be as severe
as you just described
um
yeah and um
maybe to prevent him getting the death
penalty they're saving him for hell on
earth
i think that's that's a distinct
possibility and and you know some people
have asked the question is
principled opposition to the death
penalty which is uh
which is what drives the his
extraordinary defense lawyers
reason enough
to condemn him to
to to a lifetime of of total and
profound isolation
well on that
um
happy note we'll
uh i knew we were going to end up
hopeful note
we'll move to uh questions from the
audience
first question right up front
what kind of personal life right here
what kind of personal life does putin
have
married children i mean is he capable of
having a personal life
um well
just around the time that he was getting
really serious about the traditional
values campaign he divorced his wife
which is actually
it it really is not just funny but but
very interesting because um
uh because it's such a clear indication
of how
uh
it's it's not even hypocrisy it's just
the division between sort of the rule
the rulers of russia and and the rest of
the country i mean
it doesn't even occur to him
that the same kind of rules that he
thinks should apply to the entire
population should also apply to him
so um other than that his there are lots
and lots of rumors
about his personal life
i haven't been able to corroborate any
of them
so i actually didn't include any of them
in the book
next question
uh over here
hi masha um
hi i'm wondering if you can update us on
[ __ ] riot today where are they at the
last i saw they were on house of cards
uh protesting a fake vladimir putin
right
so
the two members of [ __ ] riot uh
who ended up serving time in jail
uh
have emerged as i think really
extraordinary activists uh
they
they have founded a prisoner's rights
organization
they
they're trying to work for both
individual prisoners and
prison reform i don't think there's much
hope of getting prison reform in russia
before there's regime change
but they have been able to do a lot on
behalf of individual inmates basically
they've set up a sort of clearinghouse
for information they get uh uh people
to write in or call in about abuses and
prisons and then they they get they
mobilize people to pay attention
to a particular prison so start calling
or start writing
you know loris to start filing
complaints
and they just
save people uh you know
from from inhumane conditions or from
from extreme punishment
in these prisons
they also have a very active
international life uh which includes
uh an episode on uh you know an
appearance on the house of cards and uh
um they uh i think they've tried to use
this well and one of the things that
i've been really impressed with is that
they've they've really tried to
always find something that they can talk
about
locally so uh when they went to
australia they met with
local prisoners rights activists and um
and asked them about what issues they
should bring up in their australian
media appearances and faithfully
reproduce that message they did the same
thing when uh when they went to new york
and they um
they asked to to be able to visit
prisons uh which was complicated uh but
but they got a couple of visits in and
um but they also met with activists uh
and and they bring up issues i think
sometimes it's a little awkward and you
know in the parallels i some sometimes
fastful um but i think it's it's it's
it's it's a sophisticated and and and
extremely well-intentioned effort
question down here in the front
hi is uh
putin actually homophobic or is this
just strategic this focus on
opposing gay rights
i mean you know i don't know that
homophobia sort of rises to the standard
of
of sincere conviction i mean i think he
kind of hates people and
and he's now very happy to hate gay
people
next question on this side over here
masha thank you
i have a question also about words will
break
concrete
uh
for me the strongest most
influential part of the book for me were
the closing statements
of nadia and maria
and
my question to you is in your studying
investigating talking to them
did they create those closing statements
alone oh yes
well it is i recommend anybody to read
them because those closing statements
are so powerful they're incredible and
you know not only did they create them
alone but they wrote those closing
statements
at night
over the course of a few days
after
a nine-day grueling trial where they
would get picked up from jail at five in
the morning but driven around a
scorching hot city
in a prisoner
in a prison transport for hours then
delivered to court
the court hearing would go on for 10
hours every day
they would then be driven back to the
to the prison to get there at two in the
morning after all the searches and stuff
so they'd get like three hours of sleep
every night they were sleep deprived
they dehydrated because they couldn't
get regular bathroom breaks in court so
they they were careful not to drink too
much
um
you know these are torture conditions
and at the end of this they were able to
to write these incredibly
smart articulate moving statements
question over here on the right
uh ms gessen you're such an inspiration
to so many people
and one thing that that struck me as
rather odd as i was coming over here
today is your tenacity in in addressing
uh people who abuse power
and yet you had taken on vladimir putin
who seems
to be one of the more fearsome people on
earth and yet you're still alive whereas
whereas it seems that a fellow named i
believe freddie gray and a fellow named
eric garner and if a bunch of other
fellows who have the wrong skin color in
this country
have been facing much less fearsome
people and ending up dead and i was
wondering if you had any thoughts on the
plight of black males in the united
states today and what our
responsibilities as as a country might
be
i don't you know i don't know that i
have anything to
say besides the obvious uh part of the
reason and i always get this question
which basically boils down to you know
how come you're still walking around
and
one of the reasons i'm still walking
around is that
i have
outlets i have
people uh you know
people perceive me as being sort of
protected i
if i'm knocked off it will be noticed
there's cost
to getting rid of someone like me
and if you compare that to
even other journalists in russia who
don't get published
in the new york times and the washington
post who don't have their work
translated into other languages
who are at much greater risk precisely
because they're anonymous
i'm curious about your background
because your english is completely
fluent and was one of your parents
american
what was your journey to the us
i came here when i was 14 with my
parents
as a refugee from the soviet union and
then i went back
to the soviet union as an american
correspondent
and stayed for a very long time and sort
of became russian again
and then re-immigrated
a year and a half ago
question over here on the right
do you still want to go back to russia
say there was no danger to you or your
family would you still consider going
back do you want to go back
you mean to go back to live or
yeah um you know i'm an experienced uh i
i travel back all the time i still
report from russia uh i just it feels
much better to be based in the states
and to have my family in the states
uh i but i also i'm an experienced
immigrant so i know that when you
go you have to go and not think about uh
moving back
so i'm not
making any plans
for for moving back to russia i've made
my home in the states now
hi there um i was wondering if you could
talk a little bit about the state of
independent journalism in russia as it
is it seems to slowly be
deteriorating
oh this will be a very short answer
there's um
there's basically one print magazine
left
there's one
web-based television
channel
that used to have satellite and cable uh
outlets and now is pretty much limited
to the web and the fact that it's still
functioning is a miracle and a testament
to the incredible strength of the people
who run it
there are a couple of online
publications but they are increasingly
difficult for people to access because
the consumer authority which has been
given
almost unlimited
ability to block access to various
resources has blocked access to them
which makes them very difficult to edit
in addition to being very difficult to
read right because you can't access the
back end any easier than the front end
one of the
uh there was a very good and very big
online publication called lentaru which
was
basically uh
purged last year so its former
editor-in-chief has gone into exile and
is running a russian language
publication from riga
in latvia
with a small editorial editorial staff
in riga and a lot of reporters based on
the ground
in russia and it's quite good
but i think that uh you know and it's it
it's another heroic effort
it's really sad that uh
that the most important online
publication is now
now has to be run from exile and of
course
the moment will come when the consumer
third will block access to it
question over here on the right
yes oh thank you um recently at the
meeting with
mikhail kadarkovsky and
somebody asked towards the end so he
never really had a chance to answer
mr kardarkowski if everything will work
out as you hope and we hope what will
you do with 87 percent
so
just as one author that i recently read
calls it a golog of russian mind
russian people's minds go lag
what do you think is putting the problem
or this gulag of russian mind
that didn't hasn't leaved itself out yet
is the problem because it seems that
this country keeps on choosing
the monsters to lead them
you know i think russia is a country
that has been
taking
an incredible amount of abuse over the
last century
and when we talk about individuals who
have been abused we never expect them to
heal themselves and start being normal
all of a sudden uh for some reason when
we talk about an entire society that has
been abused we expect it to heal itself
and become normal once it has the
opportunity to to have democracy
well guess what it doesn't work that way
as it turns out and
in russia
as i mentioned at the beginning of our
conversation russia made a series of
choices
not to sort of
address its own crimes and address its
own pain
but it's uh it's easy
for us to talk about how it should have
uh it should have made other choices no
one has done that um we've never seen a
country that has
addressed its own crimes and sort of
searched its own psyche uh it's it was a
lot easier for
uh
former satellite contr soviet satellite
countries
which had the resource of the ability to
tell the story that this was imposed on
them by by someone else
and they were now rid of that occupying
power
and could go back to being their uh
great democratic uh wonderful selves
russians
would have to face up to the fact that
uh that they could they systematically
committed horrible crimes
against themselves for generations
and that
most of the time you couldn't tell the
executioners from the from the victims
or they were interchangeable
um and you know as i said we have never
seen a country do that kind of soul
searching
i can only imagine that if it's ever
done if
it will have to be done
but there will have to be some sort of
incredible
inspirational
political leader
uh who comes out of nowhere
and and takes russia down this very very
difficult path
first of all thank you so much for being
here tonight i very much enjoyed your
talk as i imagine
many of us have my question to you
relates to
any advisors or close confidants of
putin who upon whom keeper lies either
for strategic or domestic matters uh
policy uh financial wise and whether
they even do exist or if it's simply
just him running the show
i really hesitate to talk about this
because uh
i think i have an idea of how it works
some other people have other ideas about
how it works ultimately we don't know
how it works because
because it's a black box
and and in the end
it's being a black box it's the most
salient characteristic of of the system
is that it is perfectly sealed
and it's it's isolated
question over here on the right hi masha
um i just had a question on whether or
not there's any sort of
mentorship amongst maybe younger
lgbt activists in russia maybe with the
older generation even though that's kind
of
a harsh term but maybe the 90s or late
80s that kind of organized around that
time
uh
no
no
i mean i think you have
a very
uh beautiful picture of of what's
possible in russia in your head i mean
it's uh it's just a daily struggle for
survival uh for people who are trying to
do something
uh in terms of you know lgbt organizing
in russia
there is one project that's really
wonderful maybe this is what you have in
mind
it's called children 404
it's an online community started by a
journalist named lena klimova
in new zeal
who
started by writing a story about
lgbt teenagers
and was so
horrified by what she found that she
started an online community called
children 404 which which is the code
that you get when you
when you go to a page that doesn't exist
so the tagline is children 404 we exist
and it's um
she gets
dozens of letters a day
she posts a lot of them some of them
with pictures some of them would are
signed some of them are not signed it's
mostly a way for teenagers to reach out
to one another she regularly
gets i mean most of them are awful
some of them are so awful that she
starts that she gets involved in the
situation and tries to you know get
a kid out of a psychiatric hospital to
which his mother has committed him
or get a young woman
whose father has
hired someone to correctively rape her
uh to to safe haven that sort of thing
right so that's that's a sort of
mentorship but it's really more uh about
you know saving people's lives on a
daily basis
and actually there's um there's a great
documentary about this
uh community called children 404.
we're going to take one last question i
just want to invite everybody out to the
atrium immediately after the program
where masha is going to be signing books
thanks everybody
thank you
masha in a man without a face you write
about two horrendous terrorist attacks
in russia one was the apartment house i
think it was moscow and the other attack
was on a school outside of moscow
hundreds of children were killed
you conclude that the soviet excuse me
the russian security services were
responsible my question is this do you
think putin was involved or responsible
or was it a rogue action of extreme
elements in the fsb yeah i actually
don't think that the school attack was
uh was organized by the fsb i think the
school attack is much more sort of along
classic uh
lines of of a rogue terrorist
organization
uh but what happened was that in the end
during the uh
the so-called liberation attempt
uh de facto the fsb the russian secret
police and the terrorists were
were working in concert
because the fsb was working to uh
whether by design or by you know their
general ethos
was working to maximize bloodshed and
the number of casualties
um
now as with the apartment building
bomber bombings in uh
in august september 1999
um
there's a lot of evidence that points to
the fsb i would stop short of saying
that i came to the conclusion that it
was the fsb because i don't have enough
information and that's the problem
with being a journalist especially being
a journalist in a country where
none of the law enforcement agencies or
the civil oversight agencies do their
jobs i mean
um
maybe there are amazing investigative
journalists out there who can crack a
mystery like that all on their own i
don't think that's possible uh i think
we will you know journalists lack the
tools for that uh i can't collect enough
evidence i can write about what's out
there and what's out there seems to
point uh
at the fsb
well i want to thank everybody for
coming and masha gassin peter finn thank
you very much
every weekend book